so ariana grande Grande
grande grande grande anyway the one who
licked the donut you know the donut
looking one she's out with a new video
and song called God is a woman and it
has caused waves in the culture
pop culture's is is a frenzy right now
because is because of God as a woman and
it has the media like the LA Times
proclaimed that grande has officially
smashed the patriarchy with her music
video for God as a woman which just a
quick side note there we are
continuously told that this in that
thing or person has smashed the
patriarchy but then feminists continue
to complain about the patriarchy so I
thought it had been smashed I mean once
you smash something it's gone right so
like I guess that means you haven't
really been smashing it I mean if you
actually smashed it then you have to
stop complaining about it but if you're
still complaining about it then you
can't claim that you're smashing it
because clearly it's if the patriarchy
is still intact and can be smashed it
means that it was not smashed in the
past that's just a quick just a quick
note there technicality alright just a
logistical point but and there are other
Mashable says that it's the empowering
female anthem the world needs the
Guardian wrote a lengthy article
dissecting the theological aspects of
Grande's song and there's been a lot of
coverage like that of course the only
problem with dissecting the theological
aspects of the song is that there aren't
any theological aspects of the song the
video consists of the singer writhing
about in various states of undress which
is you know what most pop female pop
videos consist of these days and you
know she's gyrating on various different
objects including on the globe itself at
one point and the video is peppered with
it is peppered with a random hodgepodge
of blasphemous imageries and and things
like that at one point Madonna
comes on and quotes scripture okay so
just sort of random blasphemy going on
along with ariana grande naked prancing
about so the song itself like 98.7
percent of all pop music is just
nonsensical garbage
and it makes you manifestly stupider
just by encountering
like I will just so just so we're on the
same page okay I and kind of as a
science experiment I will read some of
the lyrics to you and I want you to be
now pay attention as I read this because
you're going to feel your own IQ
plummeting to the earth your IQ will
will lower by 13 to 15 points just when
I read a couple of lyrics from this so
you're gonna feel it you're gonna feel
yourself you're gonna say to yourself
wow I'm getting Dumber right now I could
I am I am more and by the end of it you
will be dumber than you were heading
into it so and this is just as I said
just a science experiment so the lyrics
of the song and maybe you can maybe I'm
wrong maybe there is some deep
theological significance here maybe
she's making some argument for the
womanhood of God that I that I just him
too stupid myself to pick up on but
here's what the the lyrics say you love
it how I move you you love it how I
touch you my one when all is said and
done you'll believe God is a woman and I
feel it after midnight a feeling that
you can't fight my one it lingers when
we're done you'll believe God is a woman
I don't want to waste no time yeah you
ain't got a one-track mind yeah have it
any way you like yeah and I can tell
that you know I know how I want it ain't
nobody else can relate boy I like that
you ain't afraid baby lay me down and
let's pray I'm telling you the way I
like it how I want it
but why does she I thought he or she
said that he knows he knows how she
wants it and then now she's saying that
she's gonna tell him how she wants it so
I'm trying to understand that so it
seems a little bit redundant but anyway
I could continue but your brain would
actually liquefy and leak out of your
nose if I did so I won't do that
and this is why there are several people
emailed me and they said they asked me
is like Matt can you can you do a
podcast talking about why God isn't a
woman you know can you can we can we
talk can you engage with the point that
ariana grande is making and get into a
theological debate with her pop song and
I'm not gonna do that because as you
could tell from that she's not if this
is it's just it's again it's just
nonsensical she and she's not even
really saying that God is a woman she's
saying that God is a woman because she
is God and the reason why she is God is
that she can sexually satisfy her
partner she can sexually satisfy a man
in bed so that means that she is gone
that's what she's saying
that's the theological argument that
she's making and I I mean I do disagree
with it I don't think the ability to
sexually satisfy someone makes you a God
personally that's just my my own reading
of Scripture is that that's not accurate
as far to actually engage this idea of
you know it's got a woman it's God is
not a woman neither is God a man God is
not a male or female God is not a
created being okay God is it is a being
that transcends all of that okay so we
can't put them into the labels in the
box boxes that we belong to however so
it's not so God from from the way that
we think of it like our understanding of
man and woman
God is neither he's above beyond
transcending however
it is important that we refer to God as
he for two reasons the first reason is
that if we're you know if we're not
gonna refer to God as he and we're not
going to refer it to God as she because
that would certainly be inaccurate then
we're left with something kind of
impersonal we'd have to refer to God as
it or they or something like that but
there's a reason why Scripture uses a a
personal pronoun because he is a
personal God and that's a point that has
to be driven home and you start when you
start using these kinds of vague when
you start when you start using vague
language to refer to God then you begin
to think of God as this kind of
impersonal almost this pantheistic kind
of cosmic force that's just sort of
floating out there detached from reality
and that is the kind of God that some
religions believe in it that is not the
judeo-christian God and it's not the
true God the true God is a personal God
so we have to use personal language and
referring to God why do we call him a
heat well I think it's very simple
because that's mean that Jesus tells us
to call god father
so you can argue with that if you want
you can tell Jesus he's wrong about the
nature of God if that's an argument you
want to get into with Jesus be my guest
I wouldn't recommend it but I'm not
gonna get into that argument for me it's
a it's it's it's as simple as Jesus told
us God is father call him father
in what sense is he father in what sense
can you use this
this obviously masculine label and
attach it to God I don't know I I mean I
don't know exactly I as far as the exact
nature of God I understand very little I
have just like this little tiny thimble
of understanding in my head and all I
could ever hope to do is just fill that
thimble so even if I even if I reach my
max capacity for understanding God I
will still have just a little thimble
and as it happens right now I have only
a little bit of that thimble filled so
my point is I don't I don't know exactly
but this is what Jesus Christ God
incarnate this is what he told us
so we know that God is personal and we
are to refer to him and see him as
father he
well let's put all that to the side
because really I don't want to talk
about that I wanted to talk about just
kind of pop music in general and
especially this idea that stuff like
this can it somehow empower us and
especially empower women so few point
Birk first of all the problem with this
kind of stuff I mean this kind of pop
music
is that it harms you both mentally and
spiritually it harms your mind and your
soul it's it's it's it's not a neutral I
know I was kind of kidding around about
how your IQ drops listening to it but it
was it I was only half kidding I think
it really does harm us it's not a it's
not a neutral experience
your mind is harmed because this is
nonsensical obnoxious utterly stupid and
so in order to enjoy it and when I say
stupid I don't mean it as this is it's
not a playground insult where I'm just
oh that's stupid I mean it's really
stupid it is just stupid I mean I read
it to you that is stupid because I
there's really no other word that would
better capture there's no adjective that
would better capture it then stupid and
I would use the term stupid before I
would use a term like offensive
now when you when you've got these pop
stars they start getting into the
blasphemy and everything they want you
to be offended what they're going for is
offensive but it's not nearly smart
enough to be offensive ariana grande
just doesn't have the intellectual wit
to be offensive she can't offend me it's
just really really stupid
so in order to a jet to it to enjoy it
you have to kind of wilfully kill off
the parts of your brain that demand
actual substance and actual coherence
now I would say that smart people don't
listen to this stuff but that's not
quite right because there is something
in it and I don't mean just this song in
particular I mean there's something in
pop music in general
there's something in it that that plays
to the lowest common denominator in all
of us something that that everybody
finds weirdly almost incomprehensible
appealing to some extent I don't find
this song appealing at all but everybody
has even when it comes to stupid pop
songs everyone has certain stupid pop
songs that you hear that and you're like
this is stupid I don't like it but I
also there's something about it that I
do like I can't quite understand it and
it has to do with the repetition and the
melody the beat the way I think also the
way the lyrics of these songs almost
always feed into the ego of the listener
and I think all of this could entice
even potentially smart people to listen
to it but if smart people do listen
and they keep listening and they get
enmeshed in this pop culture world then
they will become less smart in the
process they may remain smart but not as
smart and they will be smart in spite of
all this crap they're listening through
not because of it because your mind
atrophies after a while and I know
people like to say well sometimes you
got to turn your brain off and just
enjoy and what they mean is is that
they're they're talking about something
they talk the song the show the movie
whatever they're talking about when they
say well you gotta you know you just got
to turn your brain up what they're
saying is that this thing is so
completely devoid of intellectual
substance that you would be bored by it
unless you made the effort to put your
brain into kind of hibernation mode
again it's not
this this so much in pop culture the
shows the songs so much of it is just
incredibly stupid
and it's not that if you encounter it
you'll be offended it's more like if you
keep your brain on you'll be bored by it
you just it's boring
because with your brain still on yeah
you might it is possible to be
entertained with your brain on so that
your mind is also being engaged in some
way and that's a much deeper more
fulfilling more enjoyable more
entertaining form of entertainment but
if you keep your brain on and you try to
engage with ariana grande or Beyonce or
whoever you're just going to be bored to
death
so you've got to make this effort to
turn it off and yeah maybe every once in
a while it doesn't hurt to do that maybe
every once in a while it doesn't hurt to
turn your brain off and really enjoy
something completely stupid
okay maybe that doesn't although it
never really helps but maybe it doesn't
hurt but the problem is that most people
are indulging in this turn off your
brain entertainment every day for hours
at a time they turn their brain off and
they never turn it back on they say oh
sometimes you got to turn your brain off
and the only response to that is
sometimes what do you mean sometimes
what this is what you're always though
you never you never have your brain on
everything you every form of
entertainment that you enjoy is it
requires you to turn your brain up so
and you're always being entertained by
something so when exactly are you
turning it back on
um
in it's not like
the person who's always turning their
brain off
for ariana grande in company
um and for whatever reality shows and
the bachelor or whatever else it's not
like they're balancing that with
Shakespeare and documentaries about
military history you know it's
intellectually substantive but that's
not what's happening they're just their
whole life revolves around the turn your
brain off stuff and I think after a
while you get to the point where you
don't know how to turn it back on
and you don't really want to so your
mind just kinds of kind of withers after
a while in the same way that your legs
will wither if you just lay around on
the couch all the time so the mind is
hurting it and then the soul is also
hurt I think because art
can be a very very uplifting experience
and it can be edifying and it can be
enlightening and I'm not just talking
about religious art I mean any any art
any art that is rooted in something true
and that brings you closer to truth any
art that illuminates hymns in some way
and I think all arts should do that
even non-religious I mean all art should
have that effect I've said in the past
that that all art should bring us closer
to God and people always object to that
because they think that I'm saying that
all art should be religious but that's
not what I'm saying at all in fact I
would actually quite prefer it if
Christian artists like Christian
musicians Christian actors and so on
would make less Christian entertainment
quote Christian entertainment and and
make more entertainment that is
consistent with their faith but is not
explicitly evangelical so I'm actually
not a fan of this thing we do now where
you've got art you know you've got like
regular secular arts which is rooted in
nihilism and just stupidity
and materialism and then you've got
Christian art Christian movies Christian
music
Christian TM trademark you know what I
would like to see I think what will be
great is that you take some of those
Christians from over here from this
category and you bring them over into
secular entertainment and you have them
make secular entertainment that is still
consistent with and rooted in their
Christian worldview
that's the way pretty much all art used
to be in the West
up until like the mid 20th century
it's not that all art was religious it
was that all art told stories of love
and redemption and suffering and
forgiveness and justice and virtue and
sin so even if it wasn't preaching it
was still rooted in a philosophical
understanding of these things and it
would increase your own understanding to
listen to or watch or or read whatever
art form but most art today has no
connection to anything real and instead
it exists for its own sake and exists
only to distract it exists to appeal to
the basest parts of us and I think that
that certainly does hurt our souls as
well as our brains
second point
and I'm not gonna spend a lot of time on
this I just
and I'm I admit I'm not a woman myself
so maybe I'm going to engage in a little
bit of mansplaining here but when I hear
people say that stupid pop music is
empowering to women or when someone says
that the song the lyrics to which I just
read to you when someone says those
lyrics and a video of a woman naked
prancing around empowers women
I could only think that that is in
credit for but it's incredibly demeaning
and insulting to women
because the women that I know the women
in my life okay the women in my family
my own wife so there's women that I that
I know personally that if you told them
that that you know if you said to them
hey
I found this really empowering thing for
women why don't you come watch it and
then you put on the area on a grande
video for them the first thing they
would probably do is laugh at you
because they would think you were joking
and then when they realized that you
weren't joking they would be I would
think probably insulted it's like what
do you think of me that you think I'm
empowered by this idiocy are you kidding
me
turn this garbage off so the women that
I know that's that's how they would
react to that claim and I think that's
probably the case for most women
you know so this
it's it this is always the case with
modern feminism that while it claims to
be defending women and representing
women all it does is demean them and
bring them down to this level where most
women have no interest in beat
so I think there are a lot of I think I
think substantive intelligent women like
the women in my life like hopefully any
women watching this like most of the
women in the country there's a lot of
places they could look just like men
there are a lot of places we can look
for empowerment
but they're not going to look to pop
music any more than I think an
intelligent and substantive man will
look the pop music or to rap or
something for empower and the third
point I want to make this is the last
point
there's this really dumb thing that
people do where they dismiss concerns
about modern pop music on the basis that
people had similar concerns 50 years ago
and I'm sure there are people saying
this even now right now is the people
even as I'm as I'm discussing this there
are people thinking is in their head I'm
sure or people will say oh please you
know adults in the 50s we're complaining
about Elvis
and those concerns were obviously
unwarranted so what's the big deal it's
just pop music every time I hear that I
think
well yeah you're right I mean adults
were complaining about Elvis in the 50s
you're saying that their concerns were
unwarranted but were they
it seems to me now now most people in
the 50s or in the 60s or whatever
when if they were complaining about
Elvis or the Beatles they weren't
literally claiming that the world was
actually going to end because Elvis was
shaking his hips around I don't think
anyone was saying I don't think anyone
was saying that the world that all human
that all life on Earth will be
annihilated because of the shape the hip
shaking of the the pelvic thrusting of
Elvis or whatever nobody was saying I
think instead what what what perceptive
people were saying in the 50s and 60s as
pop music was coming into its own
they were noticing that this stuff is
having a Corson corseting and stupefying
effect on our culture and so what they
were worried is that art would
increasingly be debased and would be
increasingly disconnected from beauty
and truth and God and virtue and you
know in all of that and instead it would
become this course of vulgar ridiculous
stupid thing that exists only to
distract and for no other reason
I think that's what people were worried
about in the 50s when they were looking
at Elvis and
you're saying they were wrong about that
no no I think clearly they were right I
think it's quite obvious that their
concerns were 100% warranted and what
they warned would happen actually did
happen and is happening now so yes
complaints about pop music have been
around since pop music has been around
but my point is those complaints have
all been justified
they've all been proven true I mean what
are you talking about that have you
noticed what's happening in the culture
now I'm not set when you look at our
cultural state now I'm not saying that
it's the fault of pop music but pop
music has not helped
pop music has contributed to it
pop music has been both a symptom of our
cultural decline and a vehicle for it
and I think that is very clear when you
just look around you just open your eyes
we live in a culture today that is
that is just dumb
in need of constant stimulation
there are great many people in this
country who have no desire for any kind
of intellectual engagement
so they're they they have this constant
need to be entertained and the kind of
entertainment they look to is it just
gets dumber and dumber by the day and I
would submit that that's a process that
really began in earnest in the mid 20th
century and so all the people who were
pointing that out and kind of wringing
their hands about it in the mid point
they were right we probably should have
listened to them
all this so-called classic pop music of
the Beatles and Elvis I mean all that
stuff is just garbage I mean it's done
nothing good for society whatsoever
society would be would have been better
off if none of that ever existed
and I know that's supposed to be some
kind of like heresy now they said Oh
what do you mean Elvis well all of us is
a classic because he was I mean how
could you say no I mean the music is
just kind of garbage it's like what what
is what's it trying to say what's it
doing what's the point of it
what was the point of most of what the
Beatles were turning out I mean both
it's just
I submit that if we could turn back the
clock to the 40s and 50s and just go off
on a completely different path and all
the pop music just didn't it never came
about I think we'd be in a better spot
to it I'm not saying that we'd be at a
utopian spot
I don't even know how I don't know how I
don't know to what degree we'd be in a
better spot because there are so many
other problems as well but but I think
we'd be in a better spot I I don't think
the world was made better by any of this
stuff first
so once again it would seem to be the
case that the prophetic voices in the
early and mid 20th century who were
warning about this and that we probably
should have listened to them
them just like they're not listening to
those voices today that's just the story
as it goes anyway thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed